- I would never get too
hung up on mistakes.
- I make mistakes all the time.
- I need mistakes.
- Learn from those mistakes.
- I have to learn from my mistakes.
- I continually learn from my mistakes.
- Learn from your mistakes.
- Hello Believe Nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe and I believe
that entrepreneurs are going to solve
all the major problems of the world.
So to help you on your journey today,
we're going to cover how you can learn
from your mistakes.
And as always guys, if you hear something
that really resonates with you,
please leave it down
in the Comments below.
Put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well.
And when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick for yourself too, enjoy.
(orchestral music)
- I was just wondering,
what would you consider to be
the worst investment you've ever made?
- The worst investment I've ever made?
How long do you have?
(audience laughs)
Why, I've made some very bad ones
but that doesn't really bother me.
It may bother the shareholders,
but that's another question.
You're going to make mistakes in life.
There's no question about it.
You don't want to make them on
the big decisions, you know?
Who you marry and things like that.
So there's no way I'm going to make
a lot of business and investment decisions
without making some mistakes.
I may try to minimize them.
I don't dwell on them at all.
I don't look back.
The biggest mistakes are the ones
that actually don't show up.
They're mistakes of omission
rather than commission.
We've never lost that much money
on any one investment.
But it's the things
that I knew enough to do
that I didn't do.
We have missed profits
of as much as you know,
maybe 10 billion dollars and things.
That I knew enough to do, and I didn't do.
Now, the fact that I didn't
buy Microsoft way back,
is not a foregone opportunity
cause I didn't know enough
to make that decision.
But there have been other investments
where I did know enough
to make the decision
and for one reason or another,
I either didn't do it at all
or I did it on a small scale.
I was sucking my thumb
when I should have been writing checks,
you know basically.
And those don't show up.
There's no place where it
shows missed opportunities
but I've missed some big ones.
The triumphs in life are partly triumphs
because you know that everything
isn't going to be a triumph.
And I would never get
too hung up on mistakes.
I know a lot of people that
really agonize over 'em.
And it just isn't worth it.
I mean, tomorrow's another day
and you live it forward
and just go on to the next thing.
- So many people come up to me
and say, Gary it's so hard.
I look at their Instagram
and they're not posting
any of their content
with hashtags, which is a by accident way
to pick up exposure in a world
where they have no money.
When you have no money, when I took over
my dad's business, I did
three million dollars a year,
10% gross profit,
$300,000 before expenses.
My first year Marketing
budget was $14,000.
When you have no money,
and I built that business from a three
to $60 million business in five years.
I had to make every penny perfect.
So I was right about
e-mail marketing and '96.
And I was right and because of that,
I had 91% open rates.
When Google Ad Words came out,
the day it came out, I paid
five cents a click for words
before anybody bid me
up and I was super right
and that worked.
- How much is that luck verses preparation
and do you ever get anything wrong?
What do you do when you make a mistake?
- I get everything wrong, it's just that
I can't recall it, cause once it's wrong,
I'm moving on to the next thing.
Like, dwelling on what
you've fucked up on,
is the quickest way for the
next thing not to work, right?
So I think I do everything,
I mean you know this, this
is a fun thing to say.
Some people in the back know this.
I was a break-out YouTube
star in the first year, 2006.
I decided that the right strategy
was to leave YouTube completely
and go to Vidler because Vidler
offered me equity in their company.
And I've left an enormous
amount of attention,
I deviated from my intention thesis
to do short term economics
and equity in a company.
And I lost, I lost.
When DRock finally came
into my life two years ago
and we started to try to
build up my YouTube for the first time,
I was sitting on 40,000 followers
in a world where I could have had millions
if I just stayed the course.
So I make mistakes all the time.
I'm re-orging VaynerMedia every day
cause it's based on a mistake
I made the prior year.
I just don't give a
fuck about my mistakes.
Everybody else cares about your mistakes.
If you're worried about your own mistakes,
you've already lost.
- You know, I never
want to be always right
cause then I can't grow, I can't learn.
So, I have no desire to be always right,
I need mistakes you know?
And luckily enough, and knock on
this moving piano here that
my mistakes are never crucial enough
for me to be like, man, you know?
They're always great learning experiences.
- Before you succeed, you
must first learn to fail.
You know, a lot of people have failed
and get down on themselves
but the best of sports stars
learn from their mistakes.
You know, I should have did this,
okay we'll do that next year.
And just keep learning until you get
to the point to where you're the champion.
Then everybody has to compete you.
Took me eight years before
I got my first championship.
Then after that, I won three in a row,
lost two, then I got another one
and then kept losing, so it's not easy.
But you know, it's not
a specific time period
of how long it takes you, just have to
learn from your mistakes.
You make mistakes and then
just try to capitalize on that.
- [Narrator] Earlier this summer,
you were in a donut shop,
you were in California.
You said some hurtful
things about Americans
and about people's weight.
A lot of people watching
felt offended by your words.
What do you want to say?
- First of all, I mean my behavior was
very offensive and I apologize to those.
No excuse or there's
nothing to justify it.
But, you know I think
that as human beings,
we all say and do things that
we don't mean at all, sometimes.
And we have to learn from it,
I mean that's part of our process.
We have to learn from our mistakes
and that's how we grow.
- I continually learn from my mistakes
and other people's mistakes.
See, entrepreneurs think that,
hey to create that blend, our company,
our hundred million dollar company,
or even million dollar company,
you have to be very smart,
and sure, brains is part of it,
luck is a huge component.
But what I've learned over the years is,
everyone, no matter how smart you are,
you're going to fail many times
and you're going to make mistakes.
Just look at Mark Zuckerberg.
Facebook worked out.
His version of Snapchat,
that was a copycat, did
not work out, right?
So there's other areas
in which Facebook failed.
But Facebook overall as a company
has done great.
Just because you're smart doesn't mean
you're always going to succeed
with everything you try or touch.
But, every time you do something,
you will learn new things,
you'll make mistakes
and if you learn from these mistakes
and avoid making them over and over again,
you'll actually increase your odds
of succeeding as time goes on.
And the best way to do this
is not just to learn from your mistakes
but it's also to learn from
the mistakes of others.
Rockefeller, Carnegie, all these people
who are entrepreneurs,
years ago in the 1800's,
1900's, they themselves
used business principals and concepts
that are still applicable
in today's world.
Sure, we have the Internet.
But the same strategies
and concepts that they used
are still applicable, right?
So learn from their mistakes,
learn what worked for them,
what didn't work for them, why?
And bring that into
what you're doing today.
- You haven't gotten
every investment right?
Tell me about the worst
misses that you've had
or sort of, the biggest setbacks there.
- Every investment you get into,
you're getting in there
because you think you have
an airtight thesis for why this
thing is going to work out,
you're convicted, you're passionate,
you're putting not just your money in,
but all your time and effort
and your own brand and your
reputation is on the line.
And more often than not, we're wrong.
But even more painful are
some of these ones where
I didn't invest at all,
and they've gone on
to be the mega unicorns.
I think about Airbnb.
When they told me the pitch
about renting out a room
in somebody else's house
while the owner was still there,
I literally looked those guys in the eye
and I said, you guys,
this is so dangerous, man.
Somebody's going to get raped or murdered
and the blood is going
to be on your hands,
I think this is just a really bad idea.
I think they're currently raising
at a 20 billion dollar evaluation now,
so my fund probably missed out on
hundreds of millions of dollars
as a result of that, right?
- You have to learn from your mistakes.
I have this attitude that
no situation is impossible.
There is nothing impossible.
They're just continued seas
and obstacles to get around.
So if I went out and,
I'm just tryin' to think of obstacles.
Let's just say you did an opener
and she'd hear it already.
You did your lines, she'd heard it already
because your friend just approached her
with it 10 minutes ago.
Do you run screaming?
Maybe that happens the first time.
The second time, you say,
if that happens again,
what do I do?
You say, oh my God, you
must have met my friend,
that's really funny, we were
just talking about that.
Bam, problem solved.
Whatever it may be.
Say you, any problem has a solution.
So I kind of have that attitude.
You know, what if she's with eight guys?
What if you know, she is
on her way out the door?
Any problem is going to have a solution.
So you have to have that attitude.
And, if something goes wrong,
and I'm saying this in a positive way,
not a negative self-esteem way,
but if something goes wrong,
it's always your fault,
that's what I feel like.
Without being hard on myself,
if something goes wrong,
it's never her fault.
She's not a bitch,
she is not mean, she is not uptight,
I did something wrong to
make her uncomfortable.
So for example, with the openers,
I would start out, walking up and saying
hey guys, I want to get
an opinion on something,
I've got this question I'm trying to ask
and I'd start asking it.
And I noticed they
weren't really listening,
they were tuning me out,
they were kind of giving
me bad body language.
So I realized, what are they thinking?
Why is that happening?
Well it's happening because
I'm standing around,
they don't know when I'm going to leave.
So I added what's called
a time constraint.
I'd walk in, I'd say,
I want to get a quick
opinion on something,
by the way I can only stay for a second,
cause I got to re-join
my friends over there,
you know, problem solved.
So, anytime somethin' went wrong,
or maybe I would do everything,
and I felt like I was doing it perfectly,
but people weren't interested,
while I was doing it,
doing all the right things
but I was doing it in a very needy way.
A lot of people will read the material
and they'll say, this doesn't work.
Everything works.
What I say is going to be
different than what Zan says
and different from what someone else says.
But it all works, you
just have to do it right.
So for example, the opinion
openers we're talking about,
an opinion opener is how
we start a conversation.
If you go and you say,
can I ask you a question on something
and then they say, no
we're talking, get lost.
Well, the opinion openers don't work,
you just did it wrong.
You walk and you say,
hey guys I want to ask a
quick question on something.
Now you haven't asked
them a yes no question
and it's going to work.
So there's so many little subtleties,
does that make sense?
Okay so there's somebody else,
I saw somebody looking at me strangely,
so there's so many little subtleties
that you have to work in
and it's always, always
got to be your fault
if it's not working.
And not in a negative way,
not in being hard on yourself.
It's feedback so you can improve yourself.
That whole idea, there's
no such thing as failure,
but only learning lessons.
That's what I did but you know what?
I'm a guy who's hard on myself.
But I'm hard on myself cause
it makes me excel usually.
- It's been a long time
since I told stories about my boat.
But Jay and I bought a schooner,
the schooner Elizabeth.
And this is the bell off from it
and it's only important
because the boat sank.
She was kind of a nice little
boat but she leaked a lot.
That was our first big
sailing experiences.
But we bought it, we went on it,
and we sank and owned
many boats since then.
You learn from mistakes.
You got to start with faith
and belief in yourself
but that's somethin' you got
to make it your business to do.
- Knowledge is priceless okay?
Even when you make mistakes
and you learn from your mistakes.
I lost half a million
dollars on one stock,
I invested in my best
friend's dad's company,
which basically invented
print at home ticketing.
They went bankrupt and CEO,
evil person.
(laughs)
CEO bought them in bankruptcy,
changed the company name,
kept all the same contracts,
they re-sold the company
for like, 30 million.
I would have made like, 10 million
but I got wiped out.
It was a good lesson for me,
I broke my trading rules
and I didn't really know, you know,
at the time, I was
like, batting a thousand
and I had that loss.
So your losses, your
mistakes make you better.
I tell this story about Pete Sampras,
you know Pete Sampras?
- Yes.
- All right, when he was
a junior in I don't know,
I want to say like, '13, '14', '15,
he was one of the top
ranked players in the U.S.
But his coach had a
radical transformation plan
to get him to number one.
And he said Pete, hit the
ball as hard as you can.
Do you remember this story?
- No I don't.
- He hit the ball as hard as he can
and Pete's like, but
I'm not going to be able
to control it if I do that.
I was a tennis player
so I hear this story.
And the coach is like, do you trust me?
And Pete's like, yeah I do.
So hit the ball as hard as you can.
So for like, I want to
say six, nine months,
maybe even a year, Pete hit the ball
as hard as he could
and the balls were flying out,
his ranking dropped, he
was like, number six,
he dropped to like, 200.
He was just like, nobody right?
But then he gradually learned control
and he became number one
far and above anybody else.
So, sometimes you have to lose
or lose your stature at first.
And then come back stronger.
And come back so much better.
But it's tough for people to accept
because people just want success.
They think it's like, gradually building
but they don't, you know success,
there's an info-graphic that I post
on Instagram and it's
like, this is success.
- Yeah exactly.
- But eventually you learn everything.
So if you make 50 mistakes,
you learn 50 things not to do,
that makes you wiser.
But most people learn what not to do
and then they give up.
Like, heh this is so frustrating.
So you can't ever give up.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know, what was your biggest
takeaway from this video?
What are you going to immediately apply
somehow to your life or to your business?
Leave it down in the comments below,
I'm super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick shout out
to Craig Severinsen from Bright Works PR.
Craig, thank you so much
for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word.
I really, really, really appreciate it
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you,
I hope you get from me
to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.